hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack your ex or more
specifically the impossible let's play
wasabi challenge I decided that it was
long overdue since I made myself
miserable and everyone wanted me to play
this game I know that Jack Yami and Ken
all played it a long time ago but for
some reason and I think it has to do
with beauty displaying it recently
everyone wanted me to play it and I
decided I wasn't gonna play it normally
if I was gonna so wasabi every time I do
an item I'm gonna take a spoonful of
sabe you needed it's gonna be fun so
let's get started right away and know
the spoon isn't metal it is in fact
plastic
okay so that went horribly no you do not
want to see what I cut out there but
anyway that's what I get for getting
this stuff that says hard on it so it's
like hotter than normal wasabi but
anyway what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
just downgrade myself to a little dab of
or sabi before I get started on anything
else so let's go right back into the
hell I've prepared for myself and just
do a little bit little bit for the next
one I might upgrade if I get through
this baby okay here we go next very long
are you bad
okay because I'm rose this game is
messed up makes me sick this game is
just the worst
well okay watch it you Wow what what was
that what okay this is the stupidest
thing I've ever done is that because
it's like the hottest for both people is
that they keep going back for more wrong
with me let's do another cuz why die but
there's guys I love it yeah yeah dreamer
worse than anything I hate so much
people who think I'm a bass against time
night baby oh oh I didn't know this much
bodily fluid could come out of me that
sounded wrong I gotta start getting to
first I'm never gonna make it through
here oh go watch your ball
Oh beautiful
Oh Oh my hands feet are tingling hyung
is getting flashbacks to the hottest
thing oh except there's no euphoria
afterwards it's just pain but it does go
away which is the weird thing because
they think I'm back to normal then I do
it again with me it's like only a few
places he could go all by dose
left/right baltha down by stuff okay
I was about to say that was legal but so
is the murdering thing in the cabin boy
don't worry about me I'm obviously not
gonna die I choose to do this I'll be
okay with this baby oh come on she for
you boy
there's a few boy here we go go up go up
that's not right
okay who's that the party Yeti how's
your party sasquatch is is he crying and
others in terrible pain is very deadly
hot first up we got every rule
everywhere I'm time okay I know that too
trained wasabi eaters whoever that may
be this may not seem like much but I
don't really sabe I like sushi I never
even touched it wasabi other side
oh I hope these ones go quickly hahahaha
okay that cooled off what does it mean
there we go that's more like it
I'm gonna do this help shut up it helps
shut up just let me do what I do it
helps okay for real seize this time only
one left I think so let's make it a good
one
a nice dollop here we go Oh
all right oh my god Oh God look at that
ah babe okay
okay I think I'm finally done whoo that
was fun
that was a lot of fun don't bite me I'm
just gonna cry ha ha so either way thank
you all so much for watching thank you
for suggesting this game before joining
another airball double-edged blade oh ok
so if you like this please let me know
in the comments below another as
possible that's why I should do what
other challenges you can come up with
the torture me to know it at please if
you enjoyed this video share with a
friend click the like button really
please this was a rough one
oh boy but if you can share this around
by stupidity could spread around the
internet so either way thank you all so
much for watching there's more
impossible Let's Plays probably over
here is that you can click if you want
more heat there's a hot sauce challenge
I like true shocking some other what a
dodo put either way thank you again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video